hello there I'm gay I'm done we're the
slow mo guys and as you may know we are
huge gamers we don't absolutely I'm a
professional gamer
no no shut up you can have the hora
professional gamer you're terrible
you're rubbish
technically if you're paid to play games
just leading well I'm taking it shut up
well we're both very excited for the
release of Far Cry primal and in this
game there's been mammoths yeah ma'am
let's check it out so we've had big
budget increase in slow mo guys bloody
[ __ ] yep hide some scientists they've
reanimated a mammoth force he's really
cool Clive right Clive how's it going
alright chill chill chill out life so so
what a man is good for crush it
obviously crushing stuff yeah so we're
gonna fire up the Phantom turn on a
bright light and have a life here stomp
some items down hope you look pretty
good in slow-mo hmm let's do it
alright so Clyde's crushing power is
pretty forceful so we're going to shoot
this at 2,000 frames per second on the
phantom flex 4k and I've got a nice big
lovely light here which allows us to
film indoors is you need a lot of light
for slimming down I hunted mammoths hate
TVs true yes I mean there was obviously
a lot of TVs around when mammoths were
kind of out yeah so they've grown to
hate Loki is
nothing left to it I asked like turns
out he really doesn't like Christmas on
one given these three two one go
iOS this one this one is a my sculpture
on the same thing or another thing imma
take is Lego I mean they don't really
have a finger dexterity to build it so
they get very bitter and decide to trash
it what
see a layer is that some of the tables
stuck to the bottom of the foot yeah
got some breezeblocks so in the wild now
that's actually crushed watermelons and
then
Oh
damn good day's work I think closed in a
smashing job he has and I'm going to
pretend I didn't hear that pun yeah
awful so we're we're done with him we
could probably you know put them down
they're taking my back yes those kill
alright sorry Clive just kidding Clive
seriously ivories worth quite a lot and
I kind of kind of a mammoth walking
around I need a coat be sure to check
out Far Cry primal when it comes out on
Feb 23rd on Xbox one ps4 and PC yet
watch the trailer as a link in the
description below you can feel free to
follow us on Twitter subscribe to the
channel buy a shirt or a poster there's
plenty to do the world is your oyster at
this point the world is your mammoth
let's make any sense doesn't it's not
really an idiot pun alright that was
prep tell you that again leave it to me
yeah I'll let you do anything
Hey big night for Mossman